EU finance ministers meeting in Brussels  on Marcia 10th are expected to agree on  a proposal for a European fund for  strategic investments the fund part of  the Commission's investment plan for  Europe will support socially and  economically viable projects in areas  such as transport energy broadband and  infrastructure education health research  and risk finance for SMEs a deal would  speed up the process of unlocking some  funds and allowing new investment begin  as early as mid-2015 as EU leaders urged  at the summit in December 2014 ministers  will also take stock of how the  implementation of the banking Union is  progressing in particular they were  looking to instruments aimed at dealing  with the recovery and resolution of  failing banks the Commission for them  brief ministers on the situation in  member states economic policies the  council is also expected to decide under  the excessive deficit procedure to  extend the deadline for France to  correct its deficit